die impfzahlen rauschen weiter in den
keller und die regierung stolpert
unvorbereitet in den nächsten corona
winter ja das macht sich zum beispiel an
den zahlen zur dritten impfung ganz
besonders deutlich 6,1 millionen
menschen warten im moment in deutschland
auf diese dritte impfung und unser
gesundheitsminister der hat es ja
vorgemacht jetzt sparen der hat sich
gerade den dritten peaks geben lassen
hier mit gutem vorbild sozusagen
vorangegangen aber es gibt ganz ganz
viele millionen menschen in deutschland
die hätten es noch nötiger als der
bundesgesundheitsminister die sind
risikogruppe vor allen dingen unsere
alten aber jetzt läuft diese booster
impfung schon wieder total schleppend
schon wieder im schnecke deutschland
schauen wir einmal genau auf die zahlen
drauf also 4,1 millionen
pflegebedürftige gibt es in deutschland
20 prozent davon
pflegebedürftig und vollstationär in
heimen
730.000 menschen und jetzt geht es darum
eben für diese 1,8 millionen menschen
die haben diese booster impfung schon
bekommen aber eigentlich müsste es viel
viel mehr seien nämlich 6,1 millionen
bräuchten eigentlich diesen dritten
peaks wir sind schon wieder im schnecke
wir stolpern da schon wieder rein in
diesem corona spätherbst corona winter
wie kann das passieren
darüber wollen wir sprechen mit unserem
bild reporter julius böhm wir sind schon
wieder julius im schnecke du stehst
gerade vor einem altenheim wir müssen
uns schon wieder sorgen machen dass wir
unsere alten nicht genügend schützen
also wie kann das passieren
ja ich bin hier vor dem
seniorenpflegeheim tv kanal in berlin
wittenau nur stellvertretend ein
beispiel für zahlreiche hunderte fliege
heim in deutschland in denen es zu
todesfällen kam hier dezember über 100
infektionen zwölf menschen gestorben
ancona also wie gesagt nur ein beispiel
für viele viele fälle in deutschland und
wir haben das problem dass die impfung
schützt aber dass vor allem bei älteren
menschen die wirkung der impfung
nachweislich dach lässt das zeigen die
zahlen inzwischen und den menschen die
über 60 jahre alt sind das ist mal die
hauptsächlich betroffene gruppe von
corona sind über 40 prozent vollständig
geimpft müssen trotzdem ins krankenhaus
jeder dritte
der mensch definitiv station liegt war
vollständig gebe es trotzdem schwer
krank das heißt die wirkung der impfung
lässt nach und dieser dritte peaks diese
auffrischungsimpfung die ist extrem
wichtig um eben diese gruppe die ältere
menschen die wollen gruppen die vorher
kranken gruppen zu schützen und den
impfschutz aufzufrischen damit auch
diese menschen durch die womöglich
kommende vierte welle teil und ohne dass
sie versterben müssen durchkommen ist
welche fehler wurden im vergangenen jahr
bereits begangen bei den alten und bei
den pflegeheim lass uns das noch einmal
zusammenfassen im vergangenen jahr gab
es die impfung noch nicht und damals
musste man die menschen quasi noch
mechanisch schützen mit mass mit indem
man die mitarbeiter und die besucher in
den altenheimen und pflegeheim testet
schnell testet und genau das war das
problem
es gab nicht genug gemacht die masken
mann auf dem ganzen weltmarkt mangelware
schnell testen wir uns in deutschland
erst so richtig ende dezember anfang
januar eingeführt worden aber die dritte
die damals zweite welle ist schon im
oktober los geschwappt und eben in die
altenheime ein wir haben vergangene
woche über angela merkel gesprochen die
über eben diesen riesengroßen fehler
gesprochen hat man hat versucht noch die
schnellsten die altenheime zu bekommen
schleusen einzurichten damit alle
menschen die in ein altenheim ein und
aus gehen eben nicht corona eintragen
und die sowohl arabien menschen die da
leben die sehr alten menschen infizieren
weil wenn ein 80 jähriger schwer kranker
mensch erkrankt ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit sehr hoch dass er
stirbt das erste video vom anstieg dass
der nächste pfleger von bett zu bett
wandert und patient zu patient ein
bewohner der bewohner leider ansteckt
und schwere erkrankungen entstehen das
war der große fehler als noch kein
impfstoff gab jetzt haben wir den
impfstoff jetzt wissen wir auch dass die
wirkung nachlässt und deswegen ist es
dringend geboten die alten menschen mit
der dritten impfung zu schützen außerdem
eugen brysch der gleich nach unserer
gast sein wird hat auch schon gefordert
trotz der impfung wir wissen dass die
entwicklung nach erst müssen wir die
menschen testen die menschen die hier
leben die menschen die ein und aus ihnen
jeden tag testen testen testen am besten
kostenlos damit über einfach weiß wer
trägt das virus und wer trägt das virus
nicht und damit niemand unnötig
angesteckt danke julius lasse und eugen
brysch tatsächlich mit dazuholen
vorstand der deutschen stiftung
patientenschutz schönen guten morgen
herr bricht wir hören das von julius
böhm gerade noch mal dass da die nächste
corona katastrophe in den pflegeheimen
droht und unser aller jahr mehr als
gefühl ist dass wir im grunde dass die
politik nicht viel gelernt hat aus den
letzten zwei jahren und uns im kopf
bleibt immer wieder die frage wie konnte
das passieren denn bisher war es
erklärbar dadurch dass der impfstoff
nicht da ist aber jetzt ist er ja da wir
kennen alle das problem wir wissen auch
wie man millionenfach impft und es
passiert trotzdem nicht genug wie
erklären sie es
ja sie haben es auf den punkt gebracht
im frühjahr letzten jahres keine masten
keine hygiene mittel im herbst letzten
jahres keine tests nicht ausreichend und
jetzt scheint es wieder eine kombination
zu sein denn gerade die menschen in den
heimen oder die durch ambulante
pflegedienste versorgt werden sind
wieder ganz weit oben wenn es darum geht
dass wir schwere verläufe wahrnehmen
wenn es darum geht dass wir tote zählen
und dabei haben wir jetzt eigentlich
alle instrumente an der hand wir haben
die möglichkeit der booster impfung wie
sehr schleppend vorangeht das angebot
wir haben die möglichkeit der aktuellen
täglichen tests was klar nicht mehr
klappt und was noch bedauerlich ist erst
dann hatten sie herrn professor zastrow
drin in ihrer sendung und das war ja
sehr spannen er sagt ich lasse mich gar
nicht wussten denn ich habe ein antigen
test gemacht und festgestellt ich habe
eigentlich noch genügend abwehrstoffe in
meinem körper so was was eigentlich
schon seit über einem halben jahr hätte
gemacht werden könnte mich zu gucken wer
ist denn von den alten mehr gefährdet
als der andere ist intelligent mit der
impfung zu machen auch das fehlt sie
auch alles in ihrer sendung in ihrem
blatt nur diejenigen die es verantworten
nämlich bundesregierungen länder die
schauen sie zu wenig und lesen sie zu
wenig und gucken immer in die falsche
richtung nämlich auf die entwicklung auf
den intensivstationen
aber das macht ja gar keinen sinn weil
wir müssen nicht gucken ob wir die
intensivstation entlasten und belasten
wir müssen gucken dass dort wo das virus
am gefährlichsten ist nämlich bei den
alten bei den hochbetagten bei den
pflegebedürftigen gar nicht sich
entwickelt aber das tun wir nicht wir
schauen sein drei jahren in die falsche
richtung nicht dort wo die krise
entsteht und dann dort wo sie endet wir
schauen in die falsche richtung man hat
fast das gefühl der frische moment haben
wir gar keine richtungen das eben schon
thematisiert welche regierung ist jetzt
überhaupt zuständig wir sind in so einer
art grauzone und es entsteht bei vielen
bereichen das gefühl keiner kümmert sich
so richtig wer muss sich jetzt ganz
konkret kümmern vor allem wenn es ums
thema posten geht 6 millionen menschen
warten darauf müssen gepustet werden
damit sie sicher durch den winter kommen
sie sprechen es an wir haben zwei wir
haben jetzt eine konstellation die aber
auch handlungsfähigkeit möglich machen
muss das heißt wenn wir in uns in dieses
ampel koalitionspapier hineingucken wie
man durch die krise will da werden sie
das wort altenpflege gar nicht finden
denn wer das existiert für die ampel
nicht jedenfalls steht ist da nicht und
deswegen sagen wir wir brauchen endlich
sofort unverzüglich wieder mobile ins
teams die in die einrichtung gehen um
dort das angebot zu organisieren wir
brauchen tägliche tests für jedermann
der in die einrichtung kommt kostenlos
und in der einrichtung organisiert und
wir brauchen dringend die möglichkeit
den immunstatus überprüfen zu lassen
auch das lässt sich die teams
organisieren länder sind hier gefordert
wir müssen nicht warten bis etwas
geschieht sondern können sofort
reagieren und auch sofort umsetzen und
wie gesagt diese koalition dringend nach
arbeiten wenn wir sie erwarten als
ampelkoalition wir dürfen nicht die
fehler machen der letzten monate hier
muss endlich etwas geschehen dort wo der
brand entsteht muss er gelöscht werden
und nicht das fenster gelüftet damit der
rauch abziehen kann und genau das ist
der punkt wo man einen dringenden appell
an diese koalition macht die wir jetzt
zu erwarten haben endlich die fehler der
vergangenen monate nicht zu wiederholen
bisher sehe ich keine entwicklung frau
dittmer hat heute ihren blatt gesagt
naja sie wundert sich dass von denen die
im märz eigentlich da war es um die
sechs millionen eine impf angebot
bekommen haben bis jetzt nicht geschehen
ist nach meiner information war sieht
man auch an diesem runden der jetzigen
verhandlung dabei warum steht da nix
dann in diesen papieren habe zur abnahme
also schöne sprechblase ist das eine
aber politik bedeutet nicht sprechen
sondern handeln das ist laut und klar
von ihnen herr busch und trotzdem
besteht die sorge dass auch das nicht
gehört wird oder dass auch das nicht zum
handeln veranlasst was könnten jetzt
denn die betreiber von pflegeheimen
selbst machen wenn man sagt man schon
der regierung ist im moment sowieso
nichts zu erwarten weil die nicht mehr
will weil die nicht mehr kann und weil
die eben noch nicht im amt ist aber bei
mir in meinem pflegeheim das sterben
möglicherweise die bewohner wieder weg
was können die konkret unternehmen also
können die es schaffen mit persönlichem
engagement wieder eine ordentliche
testung durchzusetzen und vor allen
dingen ganz schnell durch zu boostern
bei ihnen im pflegeheim also tatsächlich
das ist der punkt auch einen
pflegeheimbetreiber hat die möglichkeit
auf die hausärzte die ja verantwortlich
dafür sind diese booster impfung in den
heimen anzubieten
einzugehen problem ist folgend ist wenn
du hundert patienten patienten hast in
einem solchen pflegeheim also
pflegebedürftige dann kann es gut sein
dass es 90 verschiedene hausärzte sind
in deutschland die sich dann um dieses
pflegeheim kümmern und und jeden einzeln
aber in einer solchen besonderen notlage
muss dass ein selbst aktiv werden auch
kontakt aufnehmen ob es gar nicht so
leicht die aus erste dann einzeln zu
bewegen ihre patienten den blick zu
nehmen weil sie gerade mal quartalsweise
nicht auch der linie sind und deswegen
eigentlich die örtlichen
gesundheitsämter heißt im team bilden
mit den kassenärztlichen vereinigungen
ist das eine darüber hinaus die tests
sind da sie anzuwenden ist dringend
notwendig nicht abzuwarten dieses
angeordnet wird sondern die kostenlosen
test sind ja vorhanden in den 1 sie
müssen nur auch konsequent eingesetzt
werden bitte nicht nur an die besucher
denken sondern insbesondere an das
personal selbst da wissen wir dass ein
gutteil dieser altenpflegekräfte sie hat
weder erstes mal noch zweites mal impfen
lassen schon irgendwie komisch ihr buch
stand jetzt die älteren geschieht alles
schon bewiesen haben dass sie dabei sind
und haben teilweise gemeindlichen
einrichtungen höre ich nur 50 oder 60
prozent der mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter mit der erstimpfung versorgt
es bleibt dabei verantwortung zu tragen
und bei den immunstatus zu überprüfen
das was das professor leistung ist dann
gesagt hat da können die heime auf die
niedergelassenen ärzte zu gehen aber
wissen sie was fehlt es gibt keine
leitlinie ab wann er welchen immunstatus
den nach geimpft werden müssen kann er
nicht jeder professor zastrow fragen von
den 900.000 ein und sagt guck mal hier
habe ich meine werte soll ich oder soll
ich nicht da hätte das erkenne ich schon
längst leitlinien dazu erlassen können
sie sehen besonders intelligent gehen
wir zur zeit immer noch nicht vor und
vor allem zu langsam
absolut sagt eugen brysch vielen
herzlichen dank für ihre einschätzungen
also heimleiterin und heimleiter die
müssen jetzt selber tätig werden so
scheint es müssen sich darum kümmern
denn auf die politik zu warten das kann
kostbare zeit kosten jetzt in dieser
situation ja und wir begrüssen jetzt bei
uns im studio unsere bildpolitik
kollegin lydia rosenfelder wir impfen
schon wieder wie die schnecken weil die
regierung nicht mehr kann nicht mehr
will weil sich niemand zuständig fühlt
aktuell in der politik für diese ja
wachsenden und ganz akuten probleme
genau was wir jetzt sehen dass das ganz
viele geimpfte senioren und pflegeheimen
impfen durchbrüche haben uns sogar im
krankenhaus landen letzte woche in bad
doberan das ist ein kleiner ort in
mecklenburg vorpommern da starben zehn
senioren alle geimpft das heißt also
dass impfen und auch die 2g regelung
schützt unsere alten nicht davor in
diesem winter wieder schwer krank zu
werden oder sogar zu versterben und dh
das einzige was hilft und eugen brysch
hat gerade auch noch gesagt das ist das
testen und zwar auch von geimpften
personals auch von den geimpften
besuchern alle müssen sich täglich
testen die in ein pflegeheim rein gehen
sonst wird es wieder und weil natürlich
werden wir nicht alle rechtzeitig
gewusst haben in diesem schneckentempo
sonst wird der winter wirklich schlimm
ist dafür zuständig wer kann das
durchsetzen dass man sagt ein pflegeheim
wird nur noch betreten von besuchern
aber auch von personal von menschen die
getestet sind also hier sind bund und
länder in der pflicht und man muss sagen
beide haben auch zu lange gewartet wir
haben die stiko empfehlung abgewartet
die dann natürlich auch kam die gilt für
die älteren für die risikopatienten und
für bestimmte berufsgruppen wie pfleger
aber wir haben nicht in derzeit
vorbereitungen getroffen wie zum
beispiel dass man die mobilen teams
schon mal in stellung bringt oder zum
beispiel die impfzentren wieder aufmacht
nie die haben wir alle geschlossen im
sommer und jetzt könnten wir sie
brauchen wir jetzt brauchen wir ganz
niedrigschwellige angebote wo jeder
sofort sich impfen lassen kann und dass
wir nicht wertvolle zeit verlieren und
genau wie im letzten jahr unsere alten
nicht wirklich schützen und diesmal
haben wir alle instrumente in der hand
wir haben die impfung wir haben die
tests werden dass das nur machen das
heißt das ist ja eine diskussion die wir
hier seit dem frühjahr im grunde führen
oder zumindest frühsommer der das heißt
du hast gerade gesagt naja natürlich
werden wir nicht alle rechtzeitig
boostern können aber natürlich ist das
was was gegangen wäre ist das verpennt
worden auch wegen des wahlkampfes weil
eben vorübergehend den handelnden
personen andere dinge wichtiger waren
als die altenheime zu schützen man hat
sich in falscher sicherheit gewogen im
sommer hat man gesehen die korona
patienten auf den intensivstationen das
sind überwiegend ungeimpfte und da waren
der impf appell alles an sich impfen
lassen aber jetzt und natürlich die die
zuerst geimpft wurden die wohlhabenden
gruppen deren m schuss schutz geht jetzt
zu ende und prüft auch gerade gesagt wir
müssen wissen wie hoch der impfschutz
bei den einsätzen nicht jeder von in den
braucht denn die booster impfung jetzt
sofort aber wir müssen das durch tests
ermitteln wie gut sind die einzelnen in
den kranken in den altenheimen geschützt
und dann können wir eben sofort die
boostern die es am dringendsten brauchen
sagte der hosenfelder vielen herzlichen
dank für deine einschätzung der besuch
hier im studio heute